i don't know why you built
this channel it's kind of a mystery wait
i don't know why
i'll tell you why i built my channel the
face it's gonna be a lot harder to roll
me this time
in an alley yeah i got rolled multiple
times
and my point is i didn't want to become
a celebrity i didn't want to become well
known but it's a lot harder
to roll somebody who's getting you know
i think i'm
i don't know if this is mistaken but i
think i'm the math phd with the largest
number of followers on twitter
and there was nothing you could do
before
i mean again to put a little
responsibility on you so you've created
something
really special for the distribution of
your own ideas i mean
but because it's not necessarily
currently scalable
you also perhaps you and i have the
responsibility
of giving other people also a chance to
spread their ideas
i mean joe rogan did this very
effectively for a bunch of people
that that's why they're angry at him
because he's a gatekeeper
and he let all sorts of people through
that gate
from roger from roger penrose to alex
jones
to uh jordan peterson to
i mean even first of all to you and to
abby martin
to add martin to barry weiss yeah
that's the problem well but you
you have not successfully built up a
thing that allows that to carry
no no no no we are all
vulnerable to reputational attack
because what happens you see the problem
lexus is that you are now an institution
at some level
you walk around with all this equipment
in a duffel bag
uh the last issue the last suit you'll
ever need
and um you have the reach
of something like cnn to people who
matter
okay so now the question is how do we
control something
that doesn't have a board doesn't have
shareholders doesn't have to make sec
files fcc
so the best answer they have is
well we just have to destroy reputations
all it takes is for us to take something
that gets said or done or alleged
i think it's incredibly important one of
the things people don't understand is
that i'm
i'm going to fight general reputational
attacks
not because some people don't deserve to
have their reputations drawn
dragged through the mud but because it's
too powerful of a tool
to hand it to cnn msnbc
princeton harvard the state department
you